too risky to stay too expensive to go
lismore's flood refugees live in limbo
when the River Rose and the city went
under in a deluge so great and so fast
it sent muddy water coursing through the
streets
[Applause]
Marco tool and his family were saved in
the nick of time that moment I'll never
forget when the helicopter came in the
damn force of that helicopter was just
unbelievable it was lifting my roof
right off the house
smashed by a wall of water his house
still stands
but ravaged by flood it's been stripped
bare and reeks of Decay now we've got no
walls the roof from the army helicopter
just leaks everywhere it looks unlivable
really yeah we've got no power it's full
of mold we can't live in it
I can't live here either
condemned houses torn down
or left to rot
covered in a thick film of muck there's
hundreds of people homeless people
living in the shells of their homes
people camping in their front or
backyards just to survive and we know
that unless we take real action to
stabilize the climate that these extreme
weather events will keep on happening
so the country's new government
renewable energy
cut methane gas emissions by a third and
reduce greenhouse gas emissions by more
than 40 percent in the next seven years
Australia has gone from being a climate
outlier to saying that it's back at the
international table and with a plan to
cut its emissions faster and deeper than
ever before
after a decade of dithering there's a
lot of ground to make up
look at the last conference we had no
pledges we had a low Target we were
doing nothing now we've had an election
people have voted with their feet they
want more we've doubled our Target we've
got all sorts of policies newly in place
so we've gone from an F to you know a
sort of a b
it's not enough out here on the flood
plain
we really can't leave because we are
we're stuck
uh we can't sell our properties for
anything
um so we can't move
[Music]
hear the sound of
sound of rain began
the gear of the next great flood
in Australia's deepening climate
disaster
Nicole Johnston Sky News Lismore
[Music]